-What week is it, Noel?
-This should give you a clue.
[pastry] My first is pudding
but never in flan.
My second in Battenberg, also in jam.
No, I meant, you're the clue.
You're a pastry.
You don't have to get involved
in an elaborate riddle.
-[pastry] Oh, I'm sorry.
-We'll talk about it later.
Welcome to…
[both] …The Great British Baking Show.
-Oh, yeah.
-What you doing?
That's Pat. He's a character actor.
Put him back!
-[Noel] This time…
-You look like a proper pizza chef.
…it's Pastry Week.
-If only we were making pizza.
-[both laugh]
[Noel] The bakers take on tarts
in the signature…
-Nelly's got a blowtorch!
-[hisses]
-…tackle filo in the technical…
-Big sausage roll. Think big sausage roll.
…and in a choux-stopping showstopper…
-[Georgie] Stinks of burning.
-…who will stand tall…
-This is where usually things go wrong.
-…and who will fall down?
[Andy] So fragile.
Oi.
[tense music playing]
-[Christiaan] Straight in the bin.
-I started so well.
[opening theme music playing]
It'll be a good week.
Some nerves is good,
I was getting too relaxed.
[Illiyin laughs]
Week five, pastry.
I'm a northern girl.
There'll not be a week goes by
that I don't make some pastry.
[indistinct conversation]
I'm good in pastry.
I says about biscuits as well I'm good.
[chuckles] And I wasn't.
So I'm gonna be quiet.
I wanna show Paul and Prue
that I deserve to be in the competition.
They saw something in me
and gave me another chance.
[Andy] Pastry on a short timescale
is very tricky,
so I'll have to cut a few corners.
Hopefully, it just comes out banging.
[bright classical music playing]
Hello, bakers, welcome back to the tent.
It's Pastry Week.
Alison, you've been with us for a while.
I'll give you a little test.
-See if you've learnt anything.
-Okay.
Can you name the five main pastries?
-Er, you've got yummy, scrummy.
-[laughs]
You've got gorgeous, lovely and delicious.
Boom, you nailed it.
[Alison] So, for your
Pastry Week signature,
the judges would like you to make
12 frangipane tarts.
You can opt for the classic
Bakewell tart flavours
or you can up with your own creation.
Now the judges are looking for
buttery shortcrust pastry,
beautifully baked frangipane
with at least one added filling.
You've got two hours to get your tart on.
[Noel] On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake.
[whimsical classical music playing]
Frangi-peen. Frangi-pain.
Is it a pain?
Bakewell tarts I've made quite a few.
Not within two hours but… [laughs]
Just need to get it all done ASAP.
So straight in with the pastry.
Ah!
When you think
of a classic frangipane tart,
you think of those classic
Bakewell flavours which are shortcrust,
you've got raspberry, then almond.
Before I moved here, I'd never had one.
I started getting them on my lunch break.
First I got a two-pack,
then it was a six-pack,
-then a 12-pack.
-[laughs]
Do you smash 'em all yourself?
Oh, honestly,
like, literally, two, three a day.
[Alison laughs]
Important thing about shortcrust pastry,
it should be short.
So that it'll crumble
and break very easily.
That it won't be tough.
[Georgie] So rub this into a breadcrumb.
Then the egg yolks,
give it a bit of a rub, knead. [laughs]
And then chill.
I want the flavour, the crispness,
the frangipane coming through,
but I also want them to look great.
And thin pastry, please.
And that can go
in the fridge now. [laughs]
[birds chirping]
-[Paul] Morning, Andy.
-Good morning.
Good morning, Prue. Hello, Noel.
What are you doing
for your frangipane tart?
This is based on nan's sweets,
Very close to my nan.
When I used to go there,
she'd have a bowl of sweets.
I'd always go for the lime chocolates.
-Yes.
-Loved them.
[Alison] Andy will combine
his favourite childhood flavours
of lime and chocolate
with an almond and pistachio frangipane.
Are you baking the frangipane
and the pastry together?
I'm gonna blind bake for ten minutes.
Come out and then frangipane'll go in,
20 minutes, 22 minutes.
That comes out. Curd goes on top.
Goes in the fridge.
You have practised this.
A few times. [laughs]
-Your pencil fell out from your ear.
-[Andy laughs]
Stop it, mate. [laughs]
-You oughta see the sharpener.
-[all laugh]
[Noel] While Andy's paying tribute
to his nan with his tarts,
Gill is also keeping family in mind.
The only nuts
that my husband likes is pistachio
so to be able to persuade him to try this,
I've had to use pistachios.
[Noel] Gill's bitesize pistachio tarts
will be topped with a blueberry compote
and piped delicately with crème diplomat.
-Tart shells, what are you using?
-Tart rings.
Oh, they are diddy.
I keep getting told off for the big ones,
so we're going delicate…
-No northern portions today.
-You could have two.
So you're going for real finesse now.
Yeah, pretty.
[Alison] Gill is reimagining the classic
Bakewell flavours with her dinky tarts,
but Georgie is taking
a more traditional approach.
I am making raspberry and almond
frangipane tarts.
Classic flavours again,
nowhere to hide with it.
[Alison] Georgie's almond frangipane tarts
will be topped with mascarpone
and Chantilly cream and raspberry gel.
Has anything changed
since you've been Star Baker?
What do you mean?
-Have you snubbed the rest of the bakers?
-Aw.
"Have you won Star Baker?
Don't talk to me unless you've won.
"Dylan, you can talk to me.
Everyone else, shh."
-Star Baker. Just getting some rest.
-[laughter]
[Noel] Georgie is relying
on classic flavours
to retain her Star Baker status…
[Nelly] Oh. Blood is everywhere.
…but Nelly is adding a cheeky twist.
It's bloody oranges.
Because I can say it, can I?
[Noel] Nelly's blood orange tarts
will be filled
with a hazelnut and almond frangipane
and topped with Italian meringue.
-How good does she look today?
-[Noel] I love it.
You look like someone off
the Guess Who? board.
I take it as a compliment.
Who chose this lovely outfit then?
My sunshine.
-Aw.
-Your sunshine.
He love Paris. And he says,
"Mum, you have to wear my hat."
-That's his hat.
-That's his hat?
So that's my lucky hat,
so I'd better go through.
-You know I'm half-French, don't you?
-Are you?
-[Noel] Yeah.
-When we going on holiday?
Let's all go together. We'll set up
a life for ourselves in France. [laughs]
-Can I get a bike?
-Yeah.
[Alison] While other bakers
are going for fruity fillings,
Dylan is taking another route.
[Dylan] Mine is coffee and chocolate.
It'll be a welcome break though,
having chocolate.
-It's the only one with chocolate.
-Really?
But mine's a fruity chocolate,
so that chocolate tastes like berries.
[Noel] Dylan's fruity chocolate ganache
will be paired with coffee gel
sitting on top of a blackberry frangipane.
-[Alison] Can I try it?
-Yeah.
What do you think?
Delicious. Killed it.
Can you just judge us? Honestly, like, I…
No, I'd be the worst judge.
I like everything.
Right, frangipane.
[Alison] To make perfect frangipane,
the bakers need to mix nuts, butter,
eggs and sugar into a spreadable paste.
It's almost like a sponge with nuts in.
It looks weird and then it gets weirder
and then it gets better. [laughs]
[Noel] And Illiyin is adding
a tropical twist to her frangipane.
[Illiyin] I am making
a toasted coconut frangipane.
I want it to taste like sunshine
and look like sunshine as well.
[Alison] Illiyin's ambitious
coconut frangipane tarts
will be topped
with a passionfruit mousse dome, mango gel
and decorated with Chantilly cream.
-Sounds absolutely wonderful.
-Good.
-But have you got enough time?
-I do.
You've practised it?
-Yeah.
-Finished in time?
-I have.
-And they were delicious?
And they looked perfect?
Yes, actually. Yes, they did. [laughs]
-Just do it all again. Just like that.
-Okay. Okay.
[Alison] With their frangipane finished…
Hopefully comes through nice and light.
…the bakers can focus on their pastry.
The star of the show.
[Noel] For the perfect ratio
of frangipane and filling,
the judges are looking for
thin tart cases.
My bases are thicker than I would like,
but I won't spend time thinning them out.
It's fiddly. It takes a while.
It's very delicate touch, yeah.
That's gone a bit skew-whiff.
Paul said I needed more finesse,
so I'm just trimming them up a little bit.
[Georgie] Tarts going in. Goodbye.
They need to be in the oven
for about 13 minutes to blind bake them.
[Nelly] Easy-peasy.
[timer beeps]
[Alison] Even though
the bake's only just begun…
-Illiyin.
-[Illiyin] What?
…there are already some problems.
Don't freak, but your tarts in the oven,
the wall's coming off.
[tense music playing]
[Illiyin] Yeah, this is not good.
I'm going home.
Oh, this is supposed to be my week.
[birds chirping]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
You've got one hour left.
I'm remaking the pastry.
They were falling where they start to sink
because I've overstretched it
and it's like, nah. And I started so well.
[Noel] But Illiyin isn't the only one
to have a problem…
[Dylan] These aren't right.
…with their blind baking.
They're awful. They're like cake.
Why has this happened?
-I had to do mine again.
-How will you have time?
I don't know. Like, I'm just gonna try.
This is so bad.
They've puffed up, which is not right.
I think I had the wrong flour.
I just need to remake my things
real quick.
[Alison] While Dylan and Illiyin
start their pastries from scratch…
[grunts]
…the others are ready
to bake their frangipanes.
[Andy] We'll get these out.
So you can see, they're quite pre-baked.
[sing-song] Perfect!
[Gill] So frangipane's going in.
[Andy] So, this is the pistachio.
Green is beautiful, isn't it?
[Christiaan] The proof is gonna be
in the frangipane.
They're in.
[Sumayah] This is my coconut frangipane.
Texture's slightly different
than a regular one. It's really nice.
It's less fine though,
'cause of the coconut.
But it's still yummy, I hope.
[Noel] Topping her tarts
with coconut crème pâtissière,
meringue and raspberry gel,
Sumayah is hoping to make up for
last week's disappointing performance.
You've made it halfway through,
that must be such a relief for you.
-Yeah.
-Is it quite stressful, doing this show?
It's stressful when you guys come.
Do you prefer me or Noel more?
[laughs]
He's gonna kill me.
He knows that.
[Andy] Just making the curd now.
[Alison] To balance their frangipane,
the bakers have been asked
to make at least one additional element.
This is gonna be the gel and the jam.
It's quite sharp. [coughs]
[Noel] But if the flavour's too strong…
There you go, wallop. We're in.
…it will overpower the frangipane.
Jam, jam, jam.
This is gonna be my apricot jam.
[Alison] And Christiaan is balancing
sweet and savoury.
My frangipane tartlets are
a cashew and black sesame frangipane.
[Noel] Christiaan's cashew
and black sesame frangipane tarts
will be topped with apricot jam
and apricot royal icing.
Congratulations on getting to
the halfway mark.
I'm just happy I made it this far.
Well, most people have got a Star Baker,
so I'm feeling this week is your week.
Let's manifest it together.
-Send these positive waves.
-Let's do it.
[both] Star Baker, Star Baker, Star Baker,
Star Baker, Star Baker, Star Baker.
-I'm going mad now.
-We're putting it out there.
-It's out there now.
-It's done.
I can chill now.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
I need to bake these,
that'll take ten minutes,
then bake them again with frangipane.
I assume it's good,
but it looks the same as last time.
[Alison] Dylan and Illiyin
are playing catch up.
Yeah, like 30 seconds.
[Noel] But it's crunch time
for the other bakers' tarts.
On the frangipane, you wanna get
a nice rise to it to make it airy.
-Three minutes, just in case.
-I'm gonna come out. [sighs]
[tense music playing]
-Oh, hello. They are very delicate.
-[timer beeping]
-Are you happy with those?
-I think so.
They look a nice colour.
They are gonna be slightly more golden
because of the toasted coconut.
Oh, shoos… did I?
Oh, fudge.
It's overbaked.
No!
Don't hear the bloody alarm again.
You're gonna taste that.
How long we got left? Tell me.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
Ah.
Except for Nelly
'cause you're wearing a beret.
-You have an hour.
-I want an hour.
This is taking much longer
than it needs to.
[Dylan] Almost done.
I can get them out, cool them.
Okay, I'm gonna start decorating.
[Gill] Just getting some glaze on.
There's the lime.
I'm just disappointed it's burnt.
[Dylan] These are done.
[Illiyin] That pastry just wasn't right.
Some of the tart cases are a bit thick,
but hopefully they pick one that's thin.
[Nelly] Now the fun'll start, yeah?
Nelly with a blowtorch, everyone!
Nelly's got a blowtorch!
-[tense music playing]
-I've lost my eyebrows!
-[hisses]
-[both laugh]
[Illiyin] They're the domes on the top.
[Gill] Done.
[Dylan] Just gotta put my ganache on.
[gasps] Such a shame.
I know I've done them way better.
[Andy] Oh, now look,
it's all come out clumsy.
[tense music continues]
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away
from your frangipane tarts.
[exhales] What a miracle.
Add some more. [laughs]
Ah, yours are so cute.
-Amazing.
-Very sexy.
It is what it is.
Just glad I got them done.
Lime's there.
Chocolate's there.
But burnt.
Aren't they pretty?
It's why it's so sad
that pastry just wasn't right.
-[rain pattering]
-[classical music playing]
[Noel] The bakers' frangipane tarts
will now be judged by Prue and Paul.
-Hello, Illiyin.
[serene classical music playing]
I do quite like the decoration.
Quite cute, but shells look terrible.
Yeah, I needed to make the pastry again.
-They all started to collapse.
-[Paul] Right.
So it's a shortcrust pastry
with a coconut frangipane,
a mango and lime gel,
topped with a passionfruit mousse dome.
I would've concentrated on one,
you know, mango or passionfruit.
That would've come out stronger.
-Pastry's a little underbaked.
-Yeah, pastry's underbaked, quite soggy.
Thank you.
[bright classical music playing]
They look really scrumptious.
Nice and shiny.
[Dylan] So mine are chocolate and coffee,
almond frangipane with some blackberries.
The pastry's nice and short
and it's baked well,
but it is chocolate and coffee.
I'm not getting the frangipane
and I wanna celebrate a frangipane.
-I couldn't taste frangipane.
-No.
[gentle classical music playing]
-They look like you want to eat them.
-[Prue] They do.
[Georgie] The tarts have a raspberry jam,
almond frangipane with Chantilly
and mascarpone cream and raspberry gel.
That's a classic Bakewell tart
in its flavour.
-[Prue] It's crisp.
-I think you've done a good job.
-Well done, Georgie.
-Thank you.
[gentle classical music playing]
Your Italian meringue
is slightly all over the place.
It's a Willy Wonka fac… chocolate factory.
-[Prue] Willy Wonka.
-A Willy Wonka chocolate factory.
But what do they taste like?
[Nelly] I have hazelnuts
and almond frangipane with blood oranges.
The blood orange is absolutely beautiful.
I like the frangipane.
I did get the blood orange,
sweetness coming from the meringue,
but your pastry's quite thick.
It overwhelms some of the tart,
to be honest.
[serene classical music playing]
-[Paul] Beautiful.
-Thank you.
Although burnt.
Okay. It's a vanilla pâte brisée
with a toasted coconut frangipane,
a coconut milk crème pât,
a raspberry jelly and toasted meringue.
You've managed to get the coconut
to come through well.
-Textures are good, but it's overbaked.
-[Sumayah] Yeah.
[gentle classical music playing]
I think they look all very even
and I like the design,
but the frangipane top,
honestly, it looks like
fried mushrooms or something.
[laughs]
[Paul] Let's have a look.
[Christiaan] The frangipane is filled
with a little layer of apricot jam
and then on top of that, we've got
a black sesame and cashew frangipane.
The sesame's not really
bringing anything to the party.
Cashew's sort of lost,
but, I mean, the flavour's okay.
The pasty is nice and crisp.
I just think
it looks a bit like sardine pâté.
-Yeah. No, fair enough.
-[Alison laughs]
[serene classical music playing]
When you're piping,
you have to be precise.
They're definitely wiggly.
I thought that might give
my personality across.
-A bit wonky and…
-[all laugh]
I've heard some waffle, mate.
But let's have a look.
[Andy] So my tarts are
a pistachio frangipane
with a lime curd and a chocolate ganache.
-[Prue] Mmm.
-[Paul] Lime curd is delicious.
-[Prue] Isn't it?
-The pistachio frangipane, delicious.
-Your pastry's burnt.
-[Prue] It is overbaked.
But I love the flavour
and I could eat a whole one.
Thank you. Thanks, guys.
[whimsical classical music playing]
-I think they look great.
-Ah!
They're very dinky. I love that.
[Alison] Pop one in your mouth.
Just do it in a oner.
So they are a pistachio frangipane,
a blueberry compote
with a crème diplomat
-and a pistachio crème.
-I mean, it's really good.
The first thing you taste is the fruit.
-The frangipane nutty taste comes in.
-[Paul] They're delicious.
The pastry's good, frangipane's good,
blueberry's good.
-Great job. Amazing.
-[Gill] Thank you.
[laughs]
I'm feeling really happy, smiley
and big cheesy grins.
But my husband said that's the best bake
that I do for this tent,
so just to warn you,
it's all downhill from here. [laughs]
[Dylan] It kind of hurt.
Normally, I can always
fall back on my flavours.
To have let myself down in that pastry
is just like, "Damn it!"
Lesson learned.
I just have to try and move on now.
Technical, who knows?
Yeah, I hope it's not f… filo
'cause I've never made that before.
[laughs]
[birds chirping]
[Noel] The bakers could practise
their frangipane tarts,
but their technical challenge
is a mystery shrouded in gingham.
Hello there, bakers.
Now, for your technical challenge.
This has been set by the prince of pastry,
Mr Paul Hollywood.
Hello, prince of pastry.
Have you got any words of wisdom?
Don't underestimate the resting time.
The wrestling time?
-The resting time.
-[Alison laughs]
Now, as always, this challenge
is judged blind, so, judges,
I'll ask you to leave the tent now.
Thank you.
-Know where they're going?
-No idea.
Prue's gonna teach Paul
how to do joined-up handwriting.
[laughs]
Paul would like you to bake
his take on the classic Greek pie.
A spanakopita.
He would like you to make
a spiral-shaped pie
with homemade filo pastry,
packed with fragrant filling
consisting of feta and spinach.
-You have two hours and 30 minutes.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake.
Never made one, never eaten one. No idea.
Spanakopi… Jesus.
Sounds like something
you go to the doctor's for.
[Prue] So, Paul, spanakopita?
[Paul] It's basically spinach feta
in a filo parcel.
Filo's all about being thin.
It's about the layers.
The longer they rest it,
the easier it is to work with.
It allows it to be rolled out
very, very thin.
I imagine they have to get
the moisture levels right inside.
[Paul] You need to pat dry the spinach
just to take out
some of that excess water.
If you don't, the whole thing'll be
soggy underneath.
And the bake is critical.
Now 45 minutes minimum
till it's nice and brown.
[Prue] Look at all those layers.
Isn't that wonderful?
Feta, spinach. It's just beautiful.
Mmm.
[Paul] Now although
that goes beautifully together,
the crispiness that comes from the filo
is the real test.
-We don't want a soggy bottom.
-No, we do not.
[birds chirping]
I mean, the instructions
are quite detailed.
"Make the pastry dough
and knead." [laughs]
Making filo's like a lost art.
Nobody does it any more.
-[Alison] Ever made filo pastry?
-Never. [laughs]
-God, Andy. We're in trouble.
-I know.
-Taxi for one.
-Taxi.
-I'll sling myself out. [laughs]
-[laughs]
You want to build up the gluten a bit,
so I am giving it a good knead.
If you don't, it won't stretch.
It'll just tear.
Don't, er, underestimate
the wrestling time.
Resting time. Sorry. [laughs]
It's only a filo pastry.
What can go wrong?
"While the dough is resting,
make the filling,
seasoning to taste."
So, what, I'm just sautéing
the, er, onions, the garlic.
I'd put in four cloves, but it says two.
And I don't want Noel to kind of, like,
fly away because it's too garlicky.
900 grammes of spinach leaf? Are they mad?
It's like a Cypress Hill video over here.
[laughs]
I assume they want it wilted
'cause they want
as little moisture as possible.
So I've blanched mine first.
So much water. It'll just soak the pie.
That's dry now 'cause it's crisping up.
I gonna add the feta cheese.
What do you feel like in that beret?
A bit sexy?
Is it? I don't know.
-Strong?
-No, no, no.
-Powerful?
-Oui, oui.
Very French.
I'm trying to but that's a game, you know.
That's a cover.
Are you undercover?
You're not in the competition, are you?
-I'm not. I'm watching you.
-An undercover cop.
-[laughs]
-I'm watching you…
They're getting close.
I'll have to go to a new show.
-[laughs]
-They nearly got me in Taskmaster.
[birds chirping]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Oh, God.
If I push it, it doesn't come back,
so it's rested for long enough.
I'm just gonna divide it
into five equal amounts.
"Take one ball and flatten it into
a rough rectangle using the rolling pin."
"Pass the pastry through the pasta machine
till you have a long,
thin length of pastry."
I'm so scared.
Oh, wait. It's actually really fun.
[laughs]
It's pretty cool. I want this.
But I already says to my husband
I want ice cream maker.
My birthday gonna be
expensive for him this year.
I'm not sure if this is right, you know.
It's really thin.
[Alison] Careful handling
of this super-thin pastry is key.
It says they want it to be 90 by 18,
so I'm just stretching it.
-[Alison] Too many holes…
-Whoopsadaisy.
…and the filling will leak out.
-I have never done this before.
-Are you joking?
You look like a proper pizza chef.
-If only we were making pizza.
-[both laugh]
-I'm gonna start that again.
-[Alison] Oh, no.
[Noel] If the bakers spend
too long rolling and rerolling…
I'm not happy with that.
…they risk running out of baking time.
What is going--
It's 'cause you're rushing the process.
[Alison] While Andy and Gill
struggle with layering up their filo…
It's just very thin and fiddly
and it doesn't like me.
…the rest of the bakers can move on
to adding their filling.
[Sumayah] It's the right length,
but it's not the right width.
[Illiyin] Gently bring
all of the pastry over.
Don't know what I'm doing.
Completely winging this.
[laughs] You look so tense.
I haven't got a clue what I'm doing.
-The secret is, nobody knows. Nobody.
-No. No.
-Correction. Nobody apart from Paul.
-Yeah, yeah.
[Nelly] As you roll, you pull.
[Christiaan] It says "Slide it in",
but I think you just go like this.
[Dylan] Just sprinkle it
with sesame seeds.
Probably bake it for, I think,
half an hour to 45 minutes. [laughs]
So it says "Bake at 180",
but I put the oven on 190.
I'm a daredevil like that. [laughs]
I'm just all fingers and arms, aren't I?
I can't afford to do this again.
Ooh, and I've just done that wrong.
We'll get it through and then do it again.
[thunder rumbling]
Bakers, you've got half an hour left.
-Oh, my gee.
-[Alison] Half an hour.
Right, big sausage roll.
Think big sausage roll.
I feel for him.
-If he can get in, it won't be as bad.
-He'll be fine. Just needs to do it.
I am proper pooping this.
I hate ya.
It'll come out last minute.
I'll keep an eye on it, but it'll need
every minute it's got and a few more.
Lost a bit of definition.
You can see it, but it's moulded into one.
Mine is really small.
Like, it should be wider.
I'm a bit concerned about some people
'cause they just put it in.
I have it 20 minutes and it's white.
It's not even gold yet.
[scatting]
Oh. [laughs] I love it.
We're ready.
[laughs]
I don't think I've got enough time,
so I've cranked up the oven a little bit.
Banging it up
just to get a bit of colour on there.
That definitely needs to go higher.
Turned the oven up again because
I want it nice and crisp on the top.
I really don't want it to be wet.
210.
-[groans]
-It's going in till the end.
It's coming out with 30 seconds…
er, I mean… [sighs]
-How long do we have left?
-Bakers, you've got one minute left.
-[screams]
-Let's do this.
Ah.
It's got more colour
than I thought it would have.
It looks nice. Let's see the bottom.
Voilà.
Not golden enough, not cooked enough.
Oh, mate, that bottom looks
scrump-diddily-umptious.
Bakers, your time is… up.
Please bring your spanakopitas
down to the table
and place them behind your photographs.
-It looks amazing.
-Cheers. Thanks.
[Illiyin] Love for it to get more colour.
[Gill] I didn't get it in quick enough.
[whimsical classical music playing]
[Noel] Paul and Prue are looking
for crisp, golden filo pastry
and a perfectly seasoned
spinach and feta filling.
Let's start with this one.
[Prue] Looks a bit soggy.
You know, you really have to
squeeze the spinach
to get all the moisture out of it,
otherwise it'll sog up the pastry.
The length's not bad.
It's lost a little bit of definition.
-Quite wet inside.
-[Prue] Yeah.
And the trouble is
the bottom pastry doesn't cook.
Yeah.
-Mmm, but it's very delicious.
-Mmm.
-Not a bad filling. Just the pastry's wet.
-[Prue] Tastes lovely.
[Paul] Moving on. Got some definition
which is good, but not quite long enough.
It's got good colour, though.
[Prue] Yeah, and it's crunchy.
That is delicious.
Nicely balanced seasoning.
It's good, 'cause it's got
a nice flake and it's not wet.
[Prue] I like that one.
[Paul] This one's a bit pale,
needed longer in the oven.
The definition is there.
-It's still wet inside.
-[Prue] Mmm.
[chuckles]
But that is delicious.
-[Paul] This is small.
-[Prue] Colour's very uneven.
[Paul] Needs longer in the oven, this.
-That is really soggy, isn't it?
-Mmm.
[Prue] The trouble is
the layers stick together.
It tastes quite nice,
but it's not what we're looking for.
[Paul] Okay, moving on.
It just started colouring.
They ran out of time,
pulled it out of the oven.
[Prue] Rolling wasn't very good.
That's a big fat bit,
that's a very thin bit.
[Paul] Needs much longer in the oven.
It's still wet inside.
The lemon level's quite high.
Moving on.
This isn't too bad.
A bit of definition here.
A little bit longer in the oven.
-[Prue] Nice flakes.
-Mmm.
The flavour's not bad.
-Nice colour, that one.
-[Prue] Good colour.
[Paul] Little bit wet.
It could be down to the spinach.
-Nice flavour.
-Yeah, lovely. Excellent flavour.
[Paul] Needed to be another loop
on the outside of that.
Struggled with the length of that one.
The colour's not bad.
-It has a nice flavour.
-[Prue] Mmm.
Bit soggy underneath but very nice.
Right.
[Alison] The judges will now rank
the spanakopitas…
-[Prue] I think we both loved the flavour.
-…from worst to best.
So, in eighth place, we have this one.
Who is this?
Gill, it's underbaked,
so it's pretty wet underneath.
In seventh spot, we have this one.
Andy, too small.
It needed to be much bigger.
[Noel] In sixth place is Georgie,
fifth place is Illiyin,
Sumayah is fourth
and Nelly is third.
And then in second place…
Who is that?
Christiaan.
It could've stayed in the oven
a little longer, but the pie, delicious.
Thank you.
And in first place, we have this one.
Dylan, not exactly perfect,
but you did have
great flavours and textures.
So, well done.
[both] Well done.
When Prue ate it and went,
"That's delicious",
that was the best reaction for me
when people eat my food.
Always the bridesmaid, never the bride.
[chuckles]
This is my third time coming second.
[laughs]
That didn't go well, did it?
From hero to zero.
I think tomorrow I'm gonna have
to bribe 'em with a lot of money.
Although looking at Paul's cars,
I don't think he needs it.
[birds chirping]
-[Georgie] No.
-[Christiaan] Here we go.
So we've had the signature
and the technical,
but I'm no clearer
as to who's doing well and who's not.
I know,
it's really extraordinary, isn't it?
You've got Gill
who did well in the signature
and didn't do so well in the tech.
She was last.
You have Dylan
that did okay-ish on the signature,
but won the technical.
Bit of that going on.
Yeah. And then we have Andy and Illiyin.
They're the ones who are in trouble.
[Paul] You've got Christiaan,
who didn't do too well in the signature
and yet came second in the technical.
So we've ended up
with a pool of people in the middle.
So it's all down to the showstopper again.
-Yes, it is.
-It's exciting but we say this every week.
Why do we bother with the signature
and technical any more?
[all laughing]
[tense classical music playing]
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your showstopper challenge.
The judges would like you to produce
a Paris-Brest centrepiece,
complete with edible stand.
[Noel] Paul and Prue would love you
to make a highly decorated gateau
consisting of large choux pastry ring
and at least one custard-based filling.
This will be a challenge for all of us.
For you guys, it'll be to make the thing.
For Noel and I, it'll be not to giggle
every time we hear the word "Brest".
[chuckles] I don't think
Paul's gonna make it.
-[Alison] We've lost.
-You have four hours.
[Alison] On your marks.
[Noel] Get set.
Bake.
I have made Paris-Brest
quite a few times before this actually,
which is surprising. [laughs]
I've made choux pastry, éclairs,
profiteroles and things like that,
but I've never made the big choux rings.
[Alison] The Paris-Brest
is a choux pastry ring
filled with praline crème mousseline…
Just about the Brest. [laughs]
…and was created in 1910
to celebrate a famous cycle race
between Paris and Brest.
[Andy] So what I can make out
is at the end of it,
the bakers would bring out
this Paris-Brest
and depict it to look like a cycle wheel.
I know I could be quite easily mistaken
for a French geezer but…
[laughs]
…I don't speak the lingo.
The choux itself is all about
that crispiness on the outside.
And you want that slight fluffiness
on the inside, but not too soft.
Because you're gonna fill that
with a mousseline, a praline, a cream.
It must be a very light
creamy filling inside
because what you don't want
is a stodgy crème pâtissière.
They have to make a stand
which is also edible.
Now they could use a biscuit,
so it'd be nice and strong.
They could use chocolate,
anything they want, but it's about
celebrating the Paris-Brest.
The last thing we want
are these stands to collapse
and the Paris-Brest
just fall all over the floor.
That would be a disaster.
-Hello, Gill.
-Hello there.
-Hello.
-So, Gill,
tell us all about your Paris-Brest.
This one is finally for my dad.
So he made a fantastic lemon meringue pie.
It's one of the first things
I baked with him, so this one's for him.
I love the idea.
I'm a fan of lemon meringue pie.
Choux pastry with cream and lemon.
What more could you want?
[laughs]
[Noel] Gill's Paris-Brest will be filled
with lemon crème mousseline and lemon curd
and topped with Italian meringue,
all sitting on an orange biscuit stand.
It's strong, it's stable,
it's worked every time I've practised it.
[laughs]
[Alison] While Gill goes
for a traditional biscuit base stand,
Sumayah is going
for a more intricate design.
My stand's gonna be made out of krokan,
and it's gonna be inspired by, like,
the tree of life and, like, Art Nouveau.
This will be fascinating.
[Alison] Sumayah's almond biscuit stand
will hold a Paris-Brest
filled with passionfruit mousseline,
topped with dark chocolate ganache.
-I've got a bone to pick with you.
-Right. I don't know what you're saying.
Alison basically said to me
that you said to her
she was your favourite.
Yeah, I did.
[groans]
-[chuckles] Really? Why, what's Alison do?
-I thought it was obvious.
Brutal. It's fine,
'cause Dylan's my favourite so…
Okay.
-We've all got our favourites.
-Yeah.
But we learn to get on with each other.
If you want.
[laughs]
[chuckles]
[Noel] Previously in favour
for his flavours…
That looks really grim at the moment.
Like a swamp.
[Alison] …Dylan might have his work
cut out to impress the judges today.
So mine has got tea in it,
so it's got matcha.
Paul's favourite thing, yeah.
-What don't you like about it?
-It's quite dry on the mouth.
'Cause they make grades of matcha.
So ceremonial grade--
-Are you using the ceremonial grade?
-Yeah, I am.
-Okay.
-I like your extraness.
-Thank you.
-[Alison chuckles]
[Noel] Dylan will serve
a matcha crème diplomat
and a roasted green tea mousseline
and will construct
a black sesame nougatine stand.
Can I just tell you something?
Sumayah reckons that
she likes Alison better than me, yeah?
Yeah.
And I said, "But Dylan likes me
better than Alison."
-Yeah.
-Is that true?
-Er, I feel like…
-That was too long, that pause.
-The thing is--
-Too long.
Was it?
[Alison] While Dylan is going
high end with his flavours…
I'm doing a pecan mousseline.
…Christiaan has got grand ambitions
for the humble pecan nut.
I wanna be the next Nigella,
and you know how she says mic…
"micro-waavey".
So I've got "pe-caan".
[laughs]
[Alison] Christiaan's pecan
and orange Paris-Brest
will sit on an almond nougatine stand
and be filled with orange crème mousseline
and pecan praline mousseline.
The pecan praline. The PP.
That sounds weird. Let's not say that.
That's not what I'm doing. Sorry.
Now I gonna do
the choux pastry for the Brest.
[Noel] The first stage
of making choux pastry
is to combine milk, water,
butter and flour.
[Illiyin] Should come together
like a smooth paste.
-[Noel] It's like mashed potato.
-This means this is good.
-That means it's good?
-The film.
-You want to have…
-Okay…
-Mmm, tasty.
-[both laughing]
If the bakers are happy
that their choux batter
has been cooked out…
[Gill] There we go.
…it's critical that they add
the right amount of eggs.
[Illiyin] When it's done,
it will hang in a V shape.
I'm the only one doing it by hand.
I prefer it 'cause I know the texture.
[Alison] If it's too dry,
it'll crack when baked.
"Do I or don't I" sort of moment.
[Alison] If it's too wet, it won't rise.
That's pretty good, actually.
Maybe it's a bit thinner than I'd like,
but there's nothing I can do now,
so it's fine.
[Gill] There's three rings.
One'll go just inside and then one on top.
-I'm gonna dust it with some nuts.
-Now it's in.
Ah! [sighs]
[Illiyin] It's about to go in the oven.
I've just got to cover it
with my hazelnuts, almonds.
[Alison] Illiyin's going for a regal look
with her nut-packed Paris-Brest.
The idea is
that it's quite like a chaotic crown.
[Noel] Illiyin's Paris-Brest crown
will be filled
with hazelnut crème diplomat
and a dark chocolate ganache
and hazelnut praline.
Sitting upon a golden chocolate stand,
the design is a nod
to her favourite TV series.
It's like a crown of nuttiness.
It's supposed to be for the mad queen from
-[whispers] Game of Thrones.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-Are you not allowed to say that?
I don't know.
I've said it loads of times.
Watch this. Game of Thrones.
-Nothing happened.
-Nothing… [chuckles]
Oh, my God.
My beautiful bakers,
you are halfway through.
[vocalising]
It's risen. It's risen lovely.
[Andy] I'm just drying this out now
to allow the steam to come out of it.
[Alison] If the bakers take their choux
out of the oven too quickly,
it will cause it to collapse.
It had a lot of rise,
then something's happened.
-Oh, dear!
-I just have to go with it.
These, they won't notice the rise much.
It'll be filled with cream.
-[Noel] But leaving it in too long…
-I think it's slightly catching.
…will cause the Paris-Brest to overbake.
Stinks of burning.
I'm gonna have to do another one.
I'm definitely gonna do that again.
I don't know what happened
but it's not a circle.
[Alison] But Christiaan's Paris-Brest
has given him a unique problem.
I don't think I'll be using this.
Gonna get rid of this.
Straight in the bin.
I'll do two choux rings
and I'll pick the best one.
[Noel] Three of the bakers need to pipe
their Paris-Brest mixture again.
It's a bit thicker this time.
Not doing anything to it.
Get in. Goodbye.
[Alison] But Nelly has got more
choux pastry to pipe than anyone else.
Now we gonna do it for this tent
just a little dot.
[Noel] And she's taking inspiration
for her choux stand from not so far away.
I'm inspired by the day,
how I feel, and what I feel.
So I'm inspired by this tree.
So it's gonna be look like
a tree trunk with flowers around.
-I never put it together.
-So it's the first time?
-Look forward to it.
-Me too, me too.
[Prue laughs]
[Alison] If Nelly can work it all out,
her Paris-Brest will be filled
with pistachio praline cream
and raspberry jam,
and her entire stand will be made
of profiteroles packed with coconut cream.
Look, this scale is cuckoo-lala.
-Cuckoo-lala. [laughs]
-Look.
What's cuckoo-lala mean?
-Is that a Slovakian thing?
-Me. Whoo!
No, it's what I made up, you know.
[Noel laughs]
Guys, I've got an announcement to make.
Nelly is cuckoo-lala.
[laughs]
-They already knew.
-They knew.
Lemon pastry cream next.
[Noel] Paul and Prue have asked
for the Paris-Brests
to be filled with at least
one custard-based filling.
I'm making a passionfruit
crème mousseline.
I'm whipping some cream
and I'll add the matcha to this.
[Georgie] This is the pistachio butter,
it's going into the crème diplomat. Lush.
[Alison] Georgie's drawing inspiration
from her Italian heritage.
[Georgie] When I was in Italy once
I had a pistachio cannoli. Obsessed.
Just, ugh, the creaminess
of the pistachio.
Absolutely love it.
[Noel] Georgie's pistachio
and raspberry Paris-Brest
will be filled with crème diplomat
and sit on stacked sponge cakes
wrapped with a chocolate collar.
So this is the sponge.
Need to get it in, get it cooled.
[gasps] Let's get going.
This is gold, this stuff.
This is the guv'nor.
So I'm just adding in my pecan paste.
[Alison] Andy's pecan-flavoured
Paris-Brest
is a tribute to his glory days.
My Paris-Brest is based
on a bar of chocolate
my partner Nicky used to get me
when we first started going out.
And then we're gonna have
a pecan mousselini inside.
-A what?
-Mousseline.
-Pecan… moussel…
-[Prue] Mousseline.
-[Alison] Mousseline.
-I thought he was a dictator.
You know what I mean.
-With a Lenin cream.
-[laughs]
[Noel] Andy's pecan
and date mousseline Paris-Brest
will sit on a stand made of toffee.
One sheet of this'll be wrapped round
and we'll be moulding it by hand.
With toffee?
Sounds precarious, but if
it's thick enough, it'll be all right.
I'll make it to one side
and no one's allowed to look at it,
touch it, poke it 'cause it is so brittle.
[chuckles]
Bakers, you only have one hour left.
[Georgie] Don't wanna know.
Don't wanna know.
It's not amazing, but this is more
what it'd look like at home as well.
[Sumayah] That one looks a lot better.
I dunno, this shape is probably better.
I'll just see which one. I've got options.
[Sumayah] Now I'm just making my stand.
So that's nice toffee.
Gotta work so quick with it
'cause it can get quite brittle.
-More choux then? [laughs]
-More choux, and more is coming.
-You've got more choux here.
-Yeah.
[Andy] It's very precarious.
I'm gonna do another one.
I'm doing another one.
Right, the cake needs to be stacked now.
So, I have to work really fast here.
[Gill] So it's supposed to look
like a flower.
[Dylan] These need to be straight.
[Georgie] Please stay.
Does it look like a tree trunk?
Not yet. [chuckles]
[Andy] It's great,
but not structurally strong.
And then it's moment of truth for me.
Mould on.
I don't think this is gonna work.
Just gotta wait and see.
[Andy] So fragile.
Just get it on.
[tense music playing]
This is where usually things go wrong.
Oi.
Ah, I put too much chocolate on it.
Oh, fudge.
[spits, sighs]
I've had it. I'm done.
You just need to take a breath.
[groans]
No, that ain't gonna work.
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
[exhales]
I need to just go, go, go.
Forget about that.
We've gotta get this done. Don't give up.
So, I just need to assemble
my Paris-Brest.
[Dylan] It looked all right in the oven.
Now it's out, it looks awful.
Just gonna pipe this up
with pistachio cream,
and between gonna go raspberries.
[Dylan] Gonna try to get as much
as possible so it has height.
[Georgie] This isn't as set
as I wanted it. It'll splodge down.
Please, God, stay.
[Nelly] Done.
Bakers, you've got one minute left.
Finish with style, right?
[Dylan] Concerned these will break
when I put this on.
[tense music playing]
[Noel] How are you?
This is not a good time to be speaking.
Please move.
Okay, that's gonna last, like,
all of ten seconds.
I'm not gonna move it now. [laughs]
Can't put any touches on it.
It's just gonna go bang.
Bakers, your time is up.
It's definitely gonna snap, the legs,
and it's gonna squish
the things underneath.
[exhales]
It's all right.
-Come on.
-I'm all right, babe. [sniffles]
Well done.
Slightly precariously placed.
[birds chirping]
[Alison] Paul and Prue have asked
for a choux pastry ring
with a creamy filling
and an edible stand
which must support the Paris-Brest.
Illiyin, can you bring up
your showstopper?
-Only if you help me. [laughs]
-[Noel] No pressure.
-I'm taking this off.
-Okay.
[chuckles]
[Illiyin] Hello.
What you should have is like that,
but between the standing and the time,
-I've got a crack there, you can see.
-[Paul] Oh, yeah.
[Illiyin] I'll put it there.
[whimsical classical music playing]
I think it looks country baking shop
-and very sophisticated at the same time.
-Thank you.
It's a shame it didn't hold up,
but let's have a look inside, shall we?
[Illiyin] You've got a choux pastry
filled with a hazelnut crème diplomat,
white chocolate and vanilla praline
and a little bit
of dark chocolate ganache.
Beautiful.
[sighs]
Oh, and when you get a bit
of praline in there, it's wonderful.
And with a well-baked choux ring
it is very, very good.
-Well done, thank you.
-Thank you.
[bright classical music playing]
That stand looks amazing, doesn't it?
The stand is amazing
from a construction point of view.
The actual Paris-Brest looks quite small
for the amount of filling it's got.
Did it rise properly?
It was a pain. I wish it'd risen better.
Will this take a little bit of weight
if I cut onto it?
[laughs]
Look at him panicking.
I have the matcha crème diplomat
and some pecan praline.
-It's not strong.
-[Prue] No.
Even though I'm not a huge fan of matcha,
it works for me.
I just think there needs to be
more choux to balance it.
[dramatic classical music playing]
[Paul] The stand is exceptional.
The detail's incredible.
It looks lovely,
and I saw it before it had begun to…
-[Paul] It has leaked out.
-[Prue] Yeah.
The Paris-Brest is crème diplomat
with pistachio, raspberry gel,
white chocolate ganache with pistachio.
I like the pistachio,
it blends well with the raspberry.
-Your choux is slightly overbaked.
-Mm.
-It's a little dry.
-[Prue] I want to taste the cake.
-[Georgie] There's raspberry cream inside.
-That's better than the top.
And the chocolate tastes delicious
with it too. Really good.
[bright classical music playing]
[Paul] It is neat.
There's elegance to that.
-But I think it looks quite short.
-It's just a small mushroom.
[chuckles]
The small profiteroles
are with coconut cream
and the Paris-Brest
is with pistachio praline cream,
raspberry jam, and cream.
And that is a very lovely
collection of fillings,
but the underside of your choux
is perfectly baked.
Inside, there's a whole layer
of doughy underbaked.
Coconut choux buns are delicious.
Your flavours are great.
-The choux is not so great.
-Okay.
[cheery classical music playing]
I think the stand is so elegant.
You know, it looks
like baroque wrought iron.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Let's have a look.
[Christiaan] So inside,
we've got a little layer of pecan praline,
orange liqueur for our mousseline,
the praline cream mousseline.
The flavours are fantastic.
The choux's okay.
But that main orange mousseline
running through it, it's just not right.
It's too thick.
But that one is absolutely perfect.
-[Paul] The praline's nice.
-Thank you.
[bright classical music playing]
I think it looks amazing.
The detail on there is incredible.
That's a clever idea.
It's a passionfruit mousseline
and a dark chocolate ganache.
[Prue] That filling is just
absolutely perfect.
Thank you.
And it's very, very strong passionfruit,
I love it.
-The choux is overbaked.
-[Sumayah] Yeah.
But because of that,
it's managed to keep its rigidity as well.
-Yeah.
-Overall, great job with the design,
-and the flavours are great.
-Thank you.
[gentle classical music playing]
[Paul] What happened with the base?
My first batch went. It just shattered.
It was always gonna be a little bit tricky
with, essentially, sugar.
So my Paris-Brest is date caramel,
a pecan mousselini.
Mousseline.
[all chuckling]
[chuckling] And it's toffee
with pecans and chocolate.
The bake on that ring is very good.
-Really?
-Not enough punch from the flavour.
I like the flavour.
I do think the mousselin-i
is a little too soft.
Right, yeah.
[bright classical music playing]
-I love the simplicity of this.
-Yeah.
You're celebrating what's on the top
and actually what is on the top is one of
the best-looking Paris-Brests in here.
[Prue] Yeah, beautiful.
So now it just has to taste great.
[Gill] The Paris-Brest has
a lemon crème mousseline,
a lemon and thyme curd,
and topped with an Italian meringue.
[all applauding]
[Prue] It tastes absolutely divine.
The filling is very lemony and sharp.
Of course, the meringue whirls on top
are very sweet.
Combination is lovely.
Think the biscuits look great. Can I…
Lovely.
Well done.
The choux is delicious,
filling's delicious.
Love the piping on the top.
-Great job. Well done.
-Thank you.
Thank you, Gill.
[jolly classical music playing]
[Andy] I'm pleased with the choux.
But using toffee wasn't the best of ideas.
I dunno what to do.
Can't bribe 'em any more.
Run out of money.
I felt I was kind of precariously placed,
pre-showstopper.
And now, there's a chance that you
could've clawed it all the way back.
I didn't get a handshake,
but I've got a Paul clap.
[Sumayah] I feel safe.
I don't take it for granted any more.
I remember at the start I was like,
"Oh, I didn't get Star Baker." [laughs]
Now I'm like,
"I just wanna stay." [laughs]
[birds chirping]
Well, it looked to me that you two
thoroughly enjoyed those showstoppers.
I loved this challenge,
and I thought they did really well.
[Paul] For me, Gill,
I rated her one of the top ones
in the showstopper today, and obviously,
she was, for me,
the top one in the signature.
Although she came last in the technical,
for me, she's dominated two of the three,
and that naturally puts her
in line for Star Baker.
And what is so interesting is, Sumayah,
who last week was so close to going home,
is in line for Star Baker.
It looked incredible.
-Her flavours were fantastic.
-Yeah.
Let's talk about Andy.
When it came to you, it was incomplete.
[Paul] It was a bad design.
You can actually
say the same about Illiyin
because she couldn't actually bring us
with the Paris-Brest on top.
Both the people whose stands fell apart,
Illiyin and Andy are both in line
for going home. Yeah.
Dear. All I'm gonna say, guys,
is I'm so glad that none of us
-were laughing at "Brest" throughout.
-[Prue chuckles]
[tense music playing]
Well done, bakers.
You survived Pastry Week.
And I've got the great job this week
of announcing which one of you
will be Star Baker.
And the person
who's Star Baker this week is…
Gill.
[all cheering]
Nice one.
[Alison] Well done.
Now, unfortunately,
I've got the terrible job
of announcing
who'll be leaving the tent today.
So, the baker leaving the tent today is…
Andy.
Sorry.
-[Paul] Wasn't your day, mate.
-No.
[Paul] Sorry, buddy.
[Andy] Just sad, you know?
I've had such a fantastic time.
I've had so many laughs,
but that's the… that's the standard.
Come to Mamma.
-[Noel laughing]
-Come to Mamma.
C'est la vie.
[Christiaan] So proud of you.
Are you proud of yourself? You should be.
Oh, it's so sad to see Andy go.
I mean, I adore the guy,
but he just didn't have a good week.
-[Paul] Well done, Gill.
-Thank you.
Gill's always remained
in a very safe position
till the last few weeks.
Today, she sort of stepped out
from the pack,
and I expect better things from her
going forward.
Star Baker.
[mouthing]
[Gill] I'm going to phone Steve.
[Steve] Absolute legend.
[laughs]
Oh, I'm so proud of you.
[Gill] Yeah, I know.
Oh, giddy.
Giddy kipper,
as my mother would say right now.
[closing theme music playing]